Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Toward the end of the 19th century, in the United States and Britain, a great threshold was crossed for the first time in the history of our species. Non-infectious causes of death, cancer, cardiovascular disorders and other chronic and degenerative diseases accounted for a greater portion of total mortality than did infectious diseases. By 1915, an American social reformer could observe that a generation ago we would only
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大约在 19 世纪末，在美国和英国，我们物种历史上第一次跨越了一个重大的门槛。非传染性死因，如癌症、心血管疾病以及其他慢性退行性疾病，在总死亡人数中所占的比例超过了传染性疾病。到 1915 年，一位美国社会改革家曾指出，一代人之前，我们只会
vainly mourn the deaths of children from disease. Today we know that every dying child accuses the community. The knowledge is available for keeping alive and well so nearly all that we may justly be said to sin in the light of the new day when we let any die. By mid-century, dying of infectious disease had become anomalous, virtually scandalous in the developed world. That is from Plagues Upon the Earth, Disease and the Course of Human History, a brilliant new book by Carl Harper, who is a professor of classics at the University of Oklahoma and wrote a fantastic book, The Fate of Rome, in which he looks at how disease impacted on the fall of the Roman Empire. Kyle is with us. Kyle, this book plagues upon the earth. I mean,
徒劳地哀悼因疾病夭折的儿童。今天我们知道，每一个夭折的儿童都在控诉整个社会。我们已经掌握了让几乎所有人都能健康活下去的知识，因此如果我们还任由任何人死去，在这个新时代的光芒下，我们无异于在犯罪。到世纪中叶，在发达国家，死于传染病已经成为一种反常现象，甚至几乎是可耻的。这段话摘自《大地的瘟疫：疾病与人类历史的进程》（Plagues Upon the Earth, Disease and the Course of Human History），这是卡尔·哈珀（Carl Harper）的一部精彩新著。他是俄克拉荷马大学的古典学教授，曾写过一本极佳的著作《罗马的命运》（The Fate of Rome），在书中他探讨了疾病如何影响罗马帝国的灭亡。凯尔今天和我们在一起。凯尔，这本《大地的瘟疫》这本书，我的意思是，
it's on a vast scale. We go from Homo erectus, the earliest ancestors of of homo sapiens right the way up to covid um and that passage that i read it's a kind of reminder to us how unusual it is that actually we're not all dying of of infectious diseases and presumably you wrote this book against the backdrop of of covid yes yes and no to your last question. And hi, thanks for inviting me to be here. I'm thrilled. And the book is sort of is a COVID book and isn't a COVID book. So I started it in 2017 when it was going to be a kind of, you know, project that I spent several years thinking about and then writing and a little bit of a abstruse academic topic, the history of infectious disease, that would have as its kind of finale a warning that the patterns of history should be another
它的时间跨度非常宏大。我们从直立人、智人的最早祖先一直讲到了新冠疫情……而我刚才读的那段话，其实是在提醒我们，事实上我们并没有全因传染病而死，这是一件多么不寻常的事情。你写这本书想必也是以新冠疫情为背景的吧？对，对，也不完全是。顺便回答你的最后一个问题，嗨，谢谢邀请我来做客，我非常高兴。这本书可以说是一本关于新冠的书，但又不仅限于新冠。我是在 2017 年开始动笔的，当时它本应是一个我计划花几年时间思考然后写作的项目，探讨的是传染病历史这样一个多少有点深奥的学术话题，而书的结尾则会是一个警告：历史的规律应该成为另一个
reason why we should obviously expect that there'll be a new pandemic. So it wasn't born as a COVID book, but it came to completion certainly under the shadow of COVID, which was pretty bizarre, pretty surreal to end up with a book that was far more urgent and resonant than I ever imagined when I started writing it. So you have this incredible passage where you say that, you know, there have basically been, it's extraordinary to think about it, actually, there have been 10,000 generations of human beings basically and for all but the last three or four the big killer was infectious i mean infectious disease was your biggest fear and that we and our parents and grandparents are completely anomalous in the
让我们显而易见地预料到将会出现新大流行的理由。所以它并非为新冠疫情而生，但它的完成确实笼罩在新冠疫情的阴影之下。最终写出这样一本比我刚开始动笔时想象的更具紧迫感和共鸣的书，这实在是相当诡异、相当超现实。所以在书中，你有这样一段令人难以置信的论述：你提到，其实仔细想想非常不可思议，人类历史上基本上经历过一万代人，而在最后的三四代人之前，最大的杀手一直是传染病——也就是说，传染病是你最大的恐惧。我们、我们的父母和祖父母在整个人类历史进程中是极其反常的，因为直到新冠疫情——
course of human history in that we have until covid COVID actually, which confronted us, forced us to sort of stare into the abyss that once confronted our predecessors, we were kind of insulated from that. So in some ways, can you genuinely divide human history, do you think, into a before and after in that way? I think it's one of the most fundamental transformations in human existence. The way we died, the way we die has so fundamentally changed. This is sometimes called the mortality transition. And it happens first in the UK and US and Western Europe, and then increasingly across the entire globe. And it's still incomplete. Of course, even in the societies today with the lowest life expectancy, life expectancy at birth has nearly tripled. So there has have to have six children on average, just to replace the population. The fact that you don't have to go
实际上是新冠疫情直面着我们，迫使我们去凝视那个曾经摆在我们先辈面前的深渊——在此之前，我们某种程度上一直受到这种威胁的庇护。所以在某种程度上，你认为真的可以把人类历史划分为这样一个“之前”和“之后”吗？我认为这是人类生存中最根本的转变之一。我们死去的方式、我们走向死亡的方式已经发生了如此根本性的改变。这有时被称为“死亡率转变”。这种情况首先在英国、美国和西欧发生，然后逐渐扩展到全球各地。而且这一过程至今尚未完成。当然，即便是当今人均预期寿命最低的社会，人类出生时的预期寿命也几乎增加了两倍。因此，过去平均必须生六个孩子，
through the experience of losing half to a third of your children. The fact that you can invest and send kids to school for 20 years to become Roman historians or something requires a kind of stability and predictability. So it's changed our ideas around pain and suffering and predictability. There's, there's nothing that this doesn't change. It changes everything. It allows the empowerment of women. And so it's easy for us to take it for granted. It's amazing. It really is only three or four generations ago. But, but how quickly we've come to build into all of our expectations about life that we shouldn't die of smallpox or tuberculosis or
仅仅为了维持人口数量。而现在你不需要经历失去三分之一甚至一半孩子的痛苦。你可以放手投资，送孩子们去上学长达二十年，让他们成为罗马史学家或从事其他行业，这需要一种稳定性和可预测性。所以它改变了我们关于痛苦、苦难和可预测性的观念。没有什么是不因此而改变的，它改变了一切。它赋予了女性赋权的可能。因此，我们很容易将这一切视为理所当然。这真的很惊人，实际上仅仅在三四代人之前，但是，我们是多么快地将“我们不应该死于天花、肺结核或”
plague or something. Because, Carl, I mean, when you, obviously, the past two years, interest in the history of disease and the relationship of humans to disease has just gone through the roof. But really, before that, there was a sense that disease is something that you can kind of park, that it's a distinct area of human history, separate from everything else, history of medicine, history of disease, whatever. But the argument of your book, basically, is that humanity's relationship to pathogens, to organisms that essentially can kill us. It's the history of everything. It's the history, I mean, you say the history of migration, the power of poverty and prosperity of progress and its unintended consequence. And that this is a history that goes back way, way before the
瘟疫之类疾病这一事实，内置到了我们对生活的所有期望中。因为，卡尔，我的意思是，当你——显然在过去的两年里，人们对疾病史以及人类与疾病关系的兴趣空前高涨。但在那之前，人们普遍认为疾病是一种你可以暂时搁置的东西，它是人类历史中一个独立的领域，与别的一切分离开来，比如医学史、疾病史等等。但你这本书的核心论点其实是：人类与病原体——也就是那些本质上能置我们于死地的有机体——之间的关系，就是一部万物之史。它是……你说它是迁徙的历史、贫困与繁荣的历史、进步及其意料之外后果的历史。而且这段历史甚至远在
emergence of Homo sapiens, that it goes back to our kind of ancestral ape ancestors. Right. And I mean, I try to look at human beings and human history the way that a biologist would, and particularly the way a disease ecologist would, because really, if you sort of lose our human arrogance and remember that we're organisms that are part of the web of life or part of nature, like any other living being. If you look at us objectively from the outside, we are very weird. And we usually think of our uniqueness in terms of our big brains and all of the good things. But, you know, if you're a chimp looking at us, our closest relative is the chimp. You might say, my goodness, that ape has so many infectious diseases. That is the germiest creature. I need
智人出现之前就已经开始了，它一直可以追溯到我们的猿类祖先。没错。我的意思是，我试图以生物学家的视角，尤其是疾病生态学家的视角来看待人类和人类历史。因为说到底，如果你抛开人类的傲慢，记住我们其实也是生命之网的一部分，是大自然的一部分，和其他任何生物一样。如果你从外部客观地审视我们，我们会发现人类非常奇怪。我们通常把自己的独特性归结于我们的大脑和种种美好的事物。但是，如果你是一只猩猩在观察我们——我们最近的近亲就是猩猩——你可能会说：“天哪，那只类人猿有那么多的传染病。那绝对是个病菌集合体。我得”
to stay away. And one of the really important ways in which we are weird, just speaking objectively, looking at us the way a biologist would, is that we have a huge number of pathogens that cause disease in us. So much more than other apes. Much more than other apes. And not only that, but we have a lot of them that are really, they're obsessed with us like a, like a creepy stalker. They really only care about us. A lot of pathogens in nature can't be too picky because you have to be able to infect different hosts, but a lot of pathogens, you know, think measles, smallpox, really, really have a narrow host range or exclusively can infect humans.
离它远点。仅从客观角度、以生物学家的眼光来看，人类极其诡异的一个非常重要的方面，就是我们身上携带了大量致病病原体。这比其他任何类人猿都要多得多。比其他类人猿多得多。不仅如此，其中还有很多病原体对我们极其执着，就像一个毛骨悚然的跟踪狂。它们真的只在乎我们。大自然中的许多病原体不会那么挑剔，因为你必须能够感染不同的宿主，但许多病原体——想想麻疹、天花——其实它们的宿主范围非常狭窄，或者只能感染人类。
That's very weird. And then it's very weird how virulent many of our diseases are. In nature, pathogens are always evolving constantly and more or less virulent strains emerge. But there are some kind of limits on the ability of pathogens to become so virulent that they kill their host so quickly that they can't survive. And so apes and a lot of animals have some really, really nasty pathogens. But we've just got a lot of really, really virulent diseases. So looking at ourselves objectively, we're weird. And one of the really important ways is the human disease pool. Why is that so broad?
这非常诡异。而且，我们的许多疾病具有如此强大的致病力（毒力），这也非常诡异。在大自然中，病原体一直在不断进化，毒性或强或弱的毒株也会层出不穷。但是，病原体演化出过高的毒性以至于迅速杀死宿主从而导致自身无法生存，这种能力是存在某种限制的。因此，类人猿和许多动物身上确实有一些非常非常讨厌的病原体。但我们人类偏偏拥有大量毒性极强、极具破坏性的疾病。所以，客观地审视我们自己，人类真的很怪异。而其中一个非常重要的体现就是人类的疾病库。为什么这个疾病库会如此庞大？
Is that to do with what becomes our history? The one word answer is history. Chimps 100,000 years ago had the same diseases that they have today, mutandis mutandis. There's always evolution. But chimps 100,000 years ago lived and died in pretty much the same way because they had the same biology and the same technology. Whereas humans 100,000 years ago did not have the same diseases. All of these diseases that I've already mentioned, measles, smallpox, tuberculosis, plague, malaria, are products of the recent past and the reason why we have the diseases we have is because of history in the sense of the the ongoing technological development that that
这和我们的历史有关吗？如果用一个词来回答，那就是：历史。十万年前的猩猩和今天的猩猩患的是同样的疾病，大同小异。演化一直在发生。但十万年前的猩猩基本上以同样的方式生老病死，因为它们拥有相同的生物学特性和相同的技术。而十万年前的人类则并非如此，我们并没有患上同样的疾病。我刚才提到的所有这些疾病——麻疹、天花、肺结核、鼠疫、疟疾——都是近代历史的产物。我们之所以会患上这些疾病，是因为历史的缘故，也就是我们这个物种所引领的
our species has has led so we live completely different lifestyles we get our food differently we live in different habitats um we live yeah so that in a social organization. One of the key to begin with is that we migrate and we occupy kind of ecological niches that our distant ancestors didn't. Yeah. Most primates are pretty stuck where they are because they evolve and adapt to their environment. They get food from, forest they live in. Chimps are very good at finding bugs to eat and fruit and occasionally a little monkey. But they're so hardwired to live in that ecological surrounding that that's it. I mean, a chimp population can't pick up and say, well, maybe we should go live in the savannah, or let's, let's check out the, the Arctic tundra and see if there's some food up there. Whereas humans are one of our most distinctive characteristics is that our, our intelligence and social capacities and technology
持续不断的技术发展所带来的结果。所以我们过着完全不同的生活方式，我们获取食物的方式不同，我们生活在不同的栖息地……我们生活在……是的，还有社会组织形式。其中一个关键点首先在于，我们不断迁徙，并占据了我们遥远的祖先所没有涉足的生态位。是的。大多数灵长类动物都被困在它们原有的地方，因为它们是针对自身环境进行演化和适应的。它们的食物来自于它们所栖息的森林。猩猩非常擅长寻找昆虫和水果来吃，偶尔也能捕获一只小猴子。但它们的基因已经死死锁定在那种生态环境中，仅此而已。我的意思是，一群猩猩不可能突然收拾包袱说：“嗯，也许我们应该去稀树草原生活，或者让我们去北极冻土带看看那里有没有什么吃的。”而人类则不同，我们最鲜明的特征之一就是我们的智力、社会能力和技术
lets us change the, the natural ecology in ways that benefit us, lets us exploit radically different environments. So we are a cosmopolitan ape. And that very fact exposes us to a huge range of potential diseases that is sort of what gets the ball rolling in terms of creating a unique and distinct human disease pool. You mentioned our use of fire in your book as one of the sort of things that, you know, crucial technological, I suppose you would say, innovation. How does that shape our relationship with disease? Yeah, it's, I mean, it's in some ways, it's the kind of technology. Humans are not the only animal that uses technology. Chimps use sticks to dig up ants and so on. So technology is not uniquely human, but human ancestors before Homo erectus had tools, very, very simple, primitive tools. But fire is sort of the
使我们能够以有利于我们自身的方式改变自然生态，让我们能够开发截然不同的环境。因此，我们是名副其实的“世界公民猿”。正是这个事实，让我们暴露在极其广泛的潜在疾病威胁之下，这正是开启并塑造独特而distinct的人类疾病库的导火索。你在书中提到了我们对火的使用，认为这是某种关键的技术，或者说你可能会称之为决定性的技术创新。这究竟是如何塑造我们与疾病的关系的？是的，我的意思是……在某种程度上，这是一种独特的技术。人类并不是唯一使用技术的动物。猩猩会用树枝去挖蚂蚁等等。因此技术并非人类独有，在直立人之前的人类祖先就已经有了工具，非常非常简单、原始的工具。但火可以说是
revolutionary technology. It puts a power in our hands that is unlike anything else in nature. It makes us the only animal that consumes energy through both metabolism and combustion. It lets us migrate. So it's what gives us the power to live in environments where otherwise it would be too cold or where otherwise the flora would be too dense. We can just burn it down.
一种革命性的技术。它赋予了我们大自然中其他任何事物都无法比拟的力量。这使我们成为唯一一种同时通过新陈代谢和燃烧来消耗能量的动物。它让我们能够进行迁徙。正是火赋予了我们在原本过于寒冷或植物过于茂密的环境中生存的能力。我们只需一把火将其烧光。
It keeps predators away from us. It lets us build other technologies like ultimately metallurgy. So fire is sort of the technology that in many ways sets the history of human technology on a different path. So it's the technology. And in that sense, I would say technology is one of the great driving forces of human history. And it's certainly one of the great driving forces that lets us change the environments we live in. And when we do that, nature will respond. Microbes are pervasive. They're everywhere. They're always evolving. They evolve fast. I mean, COVID-19 has been the best sort of public education project for understanding the evolution of, in this case,
它能帮我们驱赶捕食者。它让我们能够构建其他技术，并最终发展出冶金术。所以火可以说是这样一种技术，它在许多方面将人类技术的发展历史引向了一条截然不同的道路。这就是技术。从这个意义上说，我要说技术是推动人类历史发展的伟大动力之一，它无疑也是让我们能够改变所生活环境的伟大动力之一。而当我们这样做时，大自然就会作出回应。微生物无处不在。它们无所不在，并且一直在不断进化。它们的进化速度极快——我的意思是，新冠肺炎（COVID-19）可以说是最好的一堂公众教育课，让我们理解了病毒（在这个案例中）的演化过程。
viruses. Evolution is constant and fast. That's how we end up with these new variants. And so anytime humans change the environment, when we move to a new ecosystem, we're burning it down, we're extracting food, and we're also exposing ourselves to new pathogens driving their evolution. And fire is really what gets all of that going. Carl, have you played a computer game called Civilization? I know, but I know it, yeah. Well, you know, the way you begin with hunter-gatherers and then you progress to spaceships going to Alpha Centauri. And it's done as a sequence of sequence of amazing technological cultural leaps or whatever. But reading your book, I thought the history of humanity could
演化是持续且迅速的。这就是我们最终产生这些新变种的原因。因此，每当人类改变环境、当我们迁移到一个新的生态系统、将其付之一炬、开采食物时，我们同时也让自己暴露在新的病原体面前，并推动了它们的演化。而火正是这一切的开端。卡尔，你玩过一款叫做《文明》的电脑游戏吗？我知道，我了解它。嗯，你知道游戏的设定，你从采集狩猎者开始，然后一步步发展到飞船飞往阿尔法半岛（半人马座阿尔法星）。这一切都是通过一系列惊人的技术文化飞跃或其他方式来实现的。但读完你的书后，我发现人类的历史
just as readily be described as the expansion of diseases that can prey on us. So if we begin with hunter-gatherers, this idea that they are living in harmony with nature is not entirely true. In fact, they are going into habitats that are generating all kinds of new diseases, of which I think malaria is the most lethal. I mean, I'm sorry that I have to pile on the hunter gatherers because they, you know, they had a real moment in the 60s and 70s when it was quite popular to say that hunter-gatherers had it figured out. They, you know, they didn't have private property. They were kind of open about their sexuality. They moved around a lot. They ate a very healthy- And had a high aspirin.
同样也可以被描述为那些能够捕食我们的疾病的扩张史。因此，如果我们从采集狩猎者开始，这种认为他们与自然和谐共处的观点并非完全正确。事实上，他们正在进入那些催生出各种新疾病的栖息地，其中我认为疟疾是最致命的。我的意思是，我很抱歉我不得不把矛头指向采集狩猎者，因为他们在上世纪六七十年代曾有过一段高光时刻，当时人们非常流行一种说法，即采集狩猎者把一切都搞明白了。他们没有私有财产，他们对性持开放态度，他们经常四处走动，吃得非常健康——而且阿司匹林摄入量很高。
They're basically hippies. Yeah. Sort of, you know, bohemian paleo diet, healthy, living in harmony with nature. So that's a bit of a caricature, but there really is this sort of story that will never go away. And one of the reasons it won't go away is because there's some truth to it, that agriculture is this huge catastrophic fall from grace. And we can come back to the ways that's true and not true. But hunter-gatherer societies, we've come to really understand, were a lot more varied. There was inequality. There was ecological violence, as well as violence against humans. There was war. And our species has sort of expansionist tendencies. And another way in which we can sort of pile on the hunter-gatherers is they were not living in a kind of disease-free paradise. Now, that said, there were clearly
他们基本上就是嬉皮士。是的。某种程度上，可以说是波西米亚式的旧石器时代饮食，健康，与自然和谐共处。所以这有点像是一种讽刺性的刻画，但这种说法确实流传至今且经久不衰。它之所以挥之不去的原因之一，是因为其中确实包含着某种真相：即农业是一次巨大而灾难性的堕落。我们可以回头再探讨这种说法在哪些方面成立、在哪些方面不成立。但我们现在真正了解到，采集狩猎社会的差异性要大得多。那里存在不平等，存在生态暴力，也存在针对人类自身的暴力，还有战争。我们的物种有一种扩张主义的倾向。而我们挑剔采集狩猎者的另一个理由是，他们并没有生活在一个免于疾病的天堂里。话虽如此，这里显然也
some limits because hunter-gatherer societies tended to be small. They didn't have the energy technologies to build cities or to build really, really big, dense populations. And they moved around a lot, which isn't always a bad idea if you're trying to avoid germs to move away from your waste. But hunter-gatherers, if we, again, look at them like a biologist, they have lots of germs. And there's a lot of reasons why it's hard to know what Pleistocene people's lifestyles were like and what germs they had. But there are ways to get at that question. And most of them leave us with the answer that human hunter-gatherers already had a lot of infectious diseases and the burden of infectious diseases is already quite high. And in some cases, one of the really revolutionary things that's happening is that genetics is
存在一些局限性，因为采集狩猎社会往往规模较小。他们没有建造城市或建立非常巨大、高密度人口所需的能源技术。而且他们经常迁移，如果你想躲避病原体、远离自己的排泄物，四处迁移往往不是个坏主意。但是，如果我们再次以生物学家的眼光来看待采集狩猎者，他们身上其实携带了大量的病原体。有很多原因导致我们很难确切了解更新世（Pleistocene）人们的生活方式以及他们携带了哪些病原体。但还是有办法探究这个问题的，而大多数研究得出的答案是：人类采集狩猎者当时就已经患有大量的传染病，传染病的负担已经相当高了。在某些情况下，其中一项真正具有革命性的进展是，遗传学
letting us know about a lot of things about the evolutionary history of our germs, including giving us a better and better sense of how old some of them are. And it's increasingly evident that while a lot of our pathogens are very, very young, Some are sort of in the middle. They're not like just timeless. They don't go back to, you know, millions of years, but they do go back to the Pleistocene, the period when humans emerge, Homo sapiens emerges and starts just expanding relentlessly everywhere we can. And this expansion and process of expansion of early humans clearly reverberates back on our health. And malaria is one of the big case studies because malaria is one of the great human diseases. There are different species of the parasite that causes
让我们得以了解有关病原体演化历史的许多事情，包括让我们对其中一些病原体存在的时间有了越来越清晰的认识。人们越来越明显地发现，虽然我们的许多病原体非常非常年轻，但有些病原体则处于中间状态。它们并非那种超越时空的存在，它们的历史没有追溯到数百万年前，但它们确实可以追溯到更新世——也就是人类、智人出现并开始在我们力所能及的每个地方无情扩张的时期。这种扩张以及早期人类的扩张过程，显然对我们的健康产生了反作用。而疟疾就是其中一个重大的案例研究，因为疟疾是人类的一大主要疾病。导致疟疾的寄生虫有不同的种类。其中最严重的一种其实可能更年轻，大概直到全新世才演化出来，即恶性疟原虫（Plasmodium falciparum）。但最广泛存在的疟疾是由间日疟原虫（Plasmodium vivax）引起的，这是一种非常严重的疾病，它是一个很好的例子，我们现在认为它属于晚更新世。所以它是一种晚冰期采集狩猎者的疾病，通过蚊子传播，甚至在1万或2万年前就已经沉重地压垮了人类的健康。
malaria. The worst one is actually probably younger, probably doesn't evolve until the Holocene, Plasmodium falciparum. But the most widespread form of malaria caused by Plasmodium vivax, which is a very severe disease, is a good example of what we now think is a late Pleistocene. So it's a late Ice Age hunter-gatherer disease that is spread by mosquitoes that really would have weighed heavily on human health even 10,000, 20,000 years ago. Kyle, let me ask you a very basic question, which you've answered a bit of it already. So I think in your book, you say that basically about half of all chimpanzee deaths are caused by infectious diseases, and about just under three quarters of hunter-gatherer deaths are caused by it, which is a big difference. Is that basically because hunter-gatherer deaths are caused by, which is a big difference. Is that basically because hunter-gatherers are just moving around much more? Is that the single biggest difference?
凯尔，让我问你一个非常基础的问题，你刚才其实已经回答了一部分。我想你在书中说过，大约一半的黑猩猩死亡是由传染病引起的，而在采集狩猎者中，死于传染病的比例刚刚低于四分之三，这是一个巨大的差异。这基本上是因为采集狩猎者四处走动得更多吗？这是最主要的区别吗？他们的确比黑猩猩移动得更多。是的。我的意思是，我这里引用的是我认为非常高质量的元分析研究。过去有很多研究试图弄清楚，黑猩猩到底是因为什么死的？当然，它们没有医院和政府，但人类观察者对不同的黑猩猩群体进行了非常广泛的观察。因此，我们对黑猩猩的人口统计学和传染病情况有了相当不错的了解。我还要说的是，黑猩猩身上有很多病原体。如果你把它们与其他灵长类动物和哺乳动物进行比较，也就是我们家族树这一侧的所有生物……不过这只是家族树中糟糕的一部分，对吧？我们是这糟糕部分里最糟糕的那部分。
They're moving around more than chimpanzees are. Yeah. I mean, I'm using what I think is a very good meta study there. And there's been a lot of work trying to figure out what, you know, what do chimps die of? Of course, they don't have hospitals and governments, but human observers have looked at different chimp populations very extensively. And so we have a pretty good idea of the demography of chimpanzees and infectious diseases. I'd say this too, chimps have a lot of germs. If you compare them to other primates and other mammals, you know, everything back in our wing of the family tree. But just a bad bit of the family tree, right? We're the worst bit of a bad bit in general.
但采集狩猎者——同样，这是基于许多不同的数据点，且存在变异——大多数采集狩猎者，据我们所知，都是死于传染病。这可能和你在早期工业化英国死于的传染病不一样。它可能不是肺结核或天花，但他们死于低水平的呼吸道疾病、蠕虫感染（在评估人类健康负担时，蠕虫感染常常被严重低估），
But hunter-gatherers, and again, this is based on a lot of different data points, and there's variability. But hunter-gatherers do, most of them, from what we know, die of infectious disease. And it wouldn't be the same infectious diseases that, say, you died of in early industrial Britain. It's probably not tuberculosis and smallpox, but they're dying of low-level respiratory diseases, of worms, which is very underrated as a burden on human health. And herpes. Of gastroenteric diseases. Of what's that? Herpes. Herpes. Herpes is really old. It's been around for millions of years.
以及疱疹。死于肠胃疾病。什么？疱疹。疱疹。疱疹历史非常悠久，已经存在了数百万年。
So, and we have two, unlike most primates, we have two species of herpes virus. Spoilers. Well adapted to us. Okay. And so then just for fun, we have the agricultural revolution and we all start living in shit. Well, this is one of the interventions I'm trying to make that we can qualify and should the idea of a Neolithic revolution. It happens in two dozen places around the globe. It's not sudden, but it is still the biggest change in human lifestyles in pre-modern times. The ultimate transition from taking our food from wild
所以，与其他大多数灵长类动物不同，我们人类拥有两种疱疹病毒。剧透一下。它们非常适应我们。好吧。那么，为了好玩，我们迎来了农业革命，然后我们所有人都开始生活在粪便之中。嗯，这就是我试图提出的干预观点之一，我们可以对“新石器时代革命”这一概念进行修正和界定。它在全球两打地方发生，过程并非突发，但它仍然是前现代时期人类生活方式的最大变革。这是一个终极的转变：从从野生环境中
sources to making our food, to producing it with domesticated plants and animals. And people have talked about the importance of this change for human health and in some important ways, it changes diet, it changes patterns of labor, the stress on the human body. Um, but the, the sort of famous narratives or the big histories of disease have often sort of moved straight from the invention of agriculture to what are sometimes called the crowd diseases or the diseases of civilization, which are all respiratory diseases like measles and smallpox and so on. So I'm trying to intervene and say that story's not quite right. For one thing, it was developed at a time, I think, before radiocarbon and before we really knew how many thousands of years there were between the transition to agriculture and the rise of civilization and cities. But there's there's thousands of years in there before you really get large scale states and empires and cities in, say, Mesopotamia in the
获取食物，转变为自己生产食物，利用驯化的植物和动物进行生产。人们一直在谈论这种变革对人类健康的重要性，在某些重要方面，它改变了饮食、劳动模式以及对人体造成的压力。但是，关于疾病的那些著名叙事或宏大历史，往往直接从农业的发明跳到了有时被称为“拥挤疾病”或“文明病”的阶段，这些全都是呼吸道疾病，如麻疹、天花等等。所以我试图介入并指出：这种说法并不完全正确。一方面，这种说法的形成时期，我认为是在放射性碳测年法出现之前，也是在我们真正搞清楚从向农业过渡到文明和城市兴起之间究竟经历了多少个千年之前。但在那段漫长的时间里，有数千年的空白，直到公元前
fourth millennium BC. So that's what's going on in that stretch of time, to me, is you have this change in human lifestyle, change in the way the settlement structure, the way we live, that isn't yet big cities, but is sedentary. And this is a huge factor in disease ecology, because it means that you're constantly surrounded by your own waste, human waste. And animal waste. Humans have this really bad idea. Let's take normally mobile herds of very large body mammals that are also constantly moving away from their ways. Let's put them right in our house or yard and make sure that they don't go anywhere and that they're just all around us.
第四千纪的美索不达米亚，才真正出现了大规模的国家、帝国和城市。所以在那个时间段里发生的事情，在我看来，是人类生活方式的改变，是聚落结构和居住方式的改变——虽然还不是大城市，但已经开始定居了。这是疾病生态学中的一个巨大因素，因为这意味着你不断地被自身的排泄物（人类排泄物）所包围。还有动物排泄物。人类有一个非常糟糕的想法：让我们把原本通常四处游牧的大型哺乳动物——它们本来也会不断远离自己的排泄物——直接放进我们的房子或院子里，确保它们哪儿也去不了，就围在我们身边。
So, as I say in the book, human settlements in the early Neolithic were up to that point in time, the single greatest accumulation of interspecies scat in all of nature. There's really nothing like a human settlement that brings together so much crap from so many different animals in such a concentration. And that has a huge effect on our health. The most underrated category of disease in most histories, big history of infectious disease is diarrheal disease and dysentery. And it's, to me, this is, this is a crime that all the respiratory diseases are these big, sexy, famous named diseases that everybody knows. Whooping cough, diphtheria, measles, smallpox, scarlet fever. Fine. The respiratory diseases are important. They're sexy. They get these, these names. Whereas the diarrheal diseases don't have a chance because you can barely even say you know shigellosis and paratyphoid fever
正如我在书中所说，早期新石器时代的人类聚落，是当时自然界中单一物种间排泄物（粪便）最大规模的聚集地。世上真的没有任何事物能像人类聚落那样，在如此狭小的空间内集中了如此多不同动物的那么多排泄物。这对我们的健康产生了巨大的影响。在大多数关于传染病的宏大历史中，被低估得最厉害的一类疾病其实是腹泻病和痢疾。对我和很多人来说，这简直是一种“犯罪”：所有的呼吸道疾病都成了那些性感、出名、拥有响亮名字且人尽皆知的明星疾病。百日咳、白喉、麻疹、天花、猩红热。好吧，呼吸道疾病确实很重要，它们很“性感”，它们拥有专属的名字。而腹泻病却根本没有出头之日，因为你甚至连它们的名字都很难念顺溜——比如志贺菌病和小肠结肠炎
well they're very unglamorous aren't they they're unglamorous diseases but they they impose a huge burden on human health throughout the past they would have just been up there with particularly on children category on young particularly on children, right? And particularly in children, particularly in children, because there are lots of them and the human body will be exposed to them over time and develop some level of immunity. But it's children who are naive immunologically to these diseases. And then, of course, human children are filthy little creatures and their hygienic habits are extremely questionable. You've got four young children. I have a lot of them in my house. Speak from personal knowledge.
没错，它们很不光彩，对吧？它们是不起眼的疾病，但它们在过去给人类健康强加了极其沉重的负担，尤其是在儿童群体中——特别是针对儿童群体，对吧？尤其是儿童，特别是儿童，因为儿童数量众多，随着时间推移，人体会不断接触这些病原体并逐渐建立某种水平的免疫力。但对于这些疾病，儿童在免疫学上是完全毫无防御力的。而且，人类的幼崽本来就是肮脏的小生物，他们的卫生习惯极其成问题。你有四个年幼的孩子。我家里也有很多孩子。我是根据亲身经历说的。
It's fingernails, isn't it? Isn't it fingernails? So one of my son was tiny. He scratched my eyeball and it immediately kind of massively swelled up and I went to the doctor and the doctor said, yeah, we see this like every day because kids' fingernails, kind of massively swelled up and i went to the doctor and the doctor said yeah we have that we see this like every day because kids fingernails they're just they don't even need to go outside
就是指甲缝，对吧？难道不是指甲缝吗？我儿子很小的时候，曾经抓伤过我的眼球，我的眼睛立刻就肿得巨大。我去看医生，医生说：“是的，我们每天都能见到这种情况，因为小孩子的指甲缝里……”眼睛肿得巨大，我去了医院，医生说：“对，我们经常看到这种情况，因为小孩子的指甲缝里，他们甚至不需要去户外，
to somehow accumulate ginormous quantities of mud under their nails anyway this is they're filthy here's a question for you that might seem a very basic and dumb question so these people are are more sedentary they're living in kind of little settlements and they are surrounded by waste but obviously that waste you know attracts flies all these kinds of things and and now we would be horrified by it right we would be repelled by the stench and the sight and all these kinds of things how come it doesn't occur to people at the time that this is less than i know this is this is a great question and i think um you know i think it really challenges you as a historian to try and sympathetically think about
不知怎么就能在指甲缝里积聚巨量的泥土。总之，他们就是很脏。这里有一个问题想问你，听起来可能非常基础甚至有点愚蠢：这些人变得更加定居了，他们生活在各种小聚落里，周围环绕着排泄物。但很显然，这些排泄物会吸引苍蝇以及所有这些东西。如果我们现在看到这些，肯定会被吓坏，对吧？我们会对那种恶臭、景象以及所有这一切感到厌恶。为什么当时的人们没有意识到这不太——我知道这是一个极好的问题，我想，
the the mindset of of people in the past and i i think that actually most of our ancestors um you know they weren't indifferent they they too know, your nose tells you when something stinks that it's dangerous. That's hardwired for good reason to tell us to avoid corpses and to avoid waste because putrefaction collects all these bacteria that are unpleasant. So there may be really interesting ways in which cultural frames can partly can partly remold the wiring of, of your sensory perception and your, your cultural processing of it. But I actually think, you know, the Romans, the early Neolithic people, they, they must have wanted to avoid some of these smells. And we know that, you know, as soon as people can, they're doing everything they can to get clean water and so on. But the, um, so
作为一个历史学家，这真的挑战了你去富有同理心地思考过去人们的心态。我认为，实际上我们大多数的先辈——他们并非无动于衷，他们同样也知道，你的鼻子会告诉你当某种东西发臭时它是危险的。这种本能是深深烙印在基因里的，原因很充分，就是为了告诉我们要避开尸体和排泄物，因为腐败会滋生所有这些令人不快的细菌。因此，文化框架可能会以非常有趣的方式部分重塑你的感官知觉线路，以及你对它的文化处理方式。但我实际上认为，无论是罗马人还是早期新石器时代的人，他们一定也希望避开其中某些气味。我们知道，只要条件允许，人们就会竭尽全力去寻找干净的水等等。但是，
they weren't indifferent and I don't think we should imagine that, um, that they were, but I think they were overwhelmed and, um, the, the technology required to ensure, um, clean drinking water, um, is, is something we can't take for granted. And so I, I rather try to portray them as, as in many ways overwhelmed by the, that are at play, because they obviously they need their advantages, economic, social, cultural, spiritual advantages to living in cities. So there's a lot of forces at play here, but also the health threats and risks and challenges of living in dense settlements overwhelm them. And has it always been the case up until really the past, what, 1,500 years, 150 years, that cities can only grow if they're replenished by incomers because they kill? Yeah. I mean, I think in the big picture, all pre-modern cities are probably more or less giant demographic sinks. And that the only
他们并非无动于衷，我们不应该想象他们对卫生麻木不仁。但我认为他们当时是不堪重负的，而且确保安全饮用水所需的技术，并非我们可以视为理所当然的东西。因此，我更愿意将他们描绘成在许多方面被当时发挥作用的力量所压垮的人。因为很显然，住在城市里有其经济、社会、文化和精神上的优势，这里有许多力量在交织碰撞。但与此同时，生活在高密度聚落中的健康威胁、风险和挑战也彻底压垮了他们。一直以来，直到最近大约1500年、150年之前，城市只能靠不断涌入的新移民来补充人口，因为城市本身就是“杀手”，这种说法一直成立吗？是的。我的意思是，从宏观来看，所有前现代城市可能或多或少都是巨大的“人口黑洞”。唯一
way they can sustain their population, much less grow, is by constantly replenishing from the countryside, which tends to be less dense and therefore healthier. And there may be exceptions on the margins to some of this. And there are some places that have better environments than others. And some cities, the Japanese cities in the early modern times um are pretty pretty interesting in terms of their efforts to maintain clean and healthy environments but um but from the very well-documented western societies you know the london um the the death rate exceeds the birth rate until about 1800 um and so for london to maintain its size or grow if the death rate exceeds the birth rate until about 1800. And so for London to maintain its size or grow, if the death rate's higher than the birth rate,
能够维持人口、更不用说实现增长的方法，就是不断从农村地区补充人口。农村地区的人口密度通常较低，因此也更健康。边缘地区或许会有一些例外，某些地方的环境确实比其他地方更好。早期近代的一些日本城市在努力维护清洁健康环境方面，其做法相当有趣；但在那些资料保存完好的西方社会中，比如伦敦，死亡率一直超过出生率，直到大约1800年左右。因此，伦敦若想维持其人口规模或实现增长，在死亡率高于出生率的这段时期（大约直到1800年），
your population's going down unless there's migration. Yeah. Okay, let's take a quick break there for some ads and we will see you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on
如果死亡率高于出生率，那么除非有移民迁入，否则你的总人口数就会下降。是的。好吧，我们在这里休息一下，插播几条广告，一分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之 rest》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少量八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开
entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. dot com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are still here with Kyle Harper from the University of Oklahoma, and he is telling us about the history of disease. So, Kyle, you talked about how the advent of the Roman Empire, perhaps counterintuitively to a lot of our listeners, meant that people were shorter because they're fighting off disease, they've got diarrhea when they're young because they're living in cities. Is that true generally, would you say, through
娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、收听加更节目并优先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。我们今天依然邀请到了来自俄克拉荷马大学的卡尔·哈珀，他正在为我们讲述疾病的历史。凯尔，你刚才谈到罗马帝国的出现——这或许与我们许多听众的直觉相反——意味着人们的身高变矮了，因为他们在与疾病作斗争，由于生活在城市里，他们在年幼时就会腹泻。你认为这在整个人类历史中，对于生活在城市和大型聚落中的人们来说是一个普遍现象吗？也就是说，与那些留在田野里或者其他地方的人相比，他们会变得更矮或体型更小？是的。我的意思是，从宏观来看，我认为这确实是一种规律：留在田野里或其他地方的人……
most of human history for people who live in cities and large settlements, that they are shorter or smaller than they would otherwise have been if they had stayed in the fields or whatever? Yeah. I mean, big picture, I think that is the pattern, that they'd stayed in the fields or whatever yeah i mean a big picture i think that is that is the pattern that um that they're they're skeletons insofar as skeletons reflect health in different ways uh the skeletons tend to be shorter and and generally more stressed from urban environments than the rural environments we know that's true all over the roman empire but it's true going back further in time and coming up more recently down to, down to the modern times.
是的，从宏观来看，我认为这就是规律：他们的骨骼——就骨骼以不同方式反映健康状况而言——与农村环境相比，来自城市环境的骨骼往往更矮小，受到的生理压力也普遍更大。我们知道这在整个罗马帝国都是如此，而且这种现象可以追溯到更早的古代，并一直延续到更近的近代。
So Tom, you know why I asked Carl that question? Because you often give me grief in this podcast about not living in London. And now I've been proved completely and utterly right. No, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Around 1900.
所以，汤姆，你知道我为什么问卡尔那个问题吗？因为你经常在这个播客里因为我不住在伦敦而数落我。现在我被证明是完全彻底地正确了。不，对不起。抱歉。大约在1900年。
Yeah. It all changes, Dominic. Get with the, get with the speed. It flips. Somewhere in the 20th century, you're,
是的。一切都变了，多米尼克。跟上时代的发展节奏吧。情况逆转了。在20世纪的某个时期，你……
the deep continuities of human history prove me right, Tom. No, the Metropolitan League get better health than the peasants, I'm afraid, are left behind. That's the lesson of history, Dominic, and you can't argue with it. But of course, the most famous plague pandemic is in the 14th century the black death how do you think that the impact of that of the black death compares to the justinianic plague or to any other um pandemic experience before that before the black death yeah i mean one of the one of the things i really wanted to do in writing a history of disease is to to broaden the the canvas and make sure that we're we're not just focusing on the big sexy diseases,
人类历史的深刻连续性证明我是对的，汤姆。不，恐怕大都市的居民比那些被甩在后面的农民拥有更好的健康状况。这就是历史给我们的教训，多米尼克，这是无可争辩的。当然，最著名的瘟疫大流行发生在14世纪的黑死病。你认为黑死病的冲击与查士丁尼瘟疫或黑死病之前任何其他大流行经历相比，究竟有何不同？是的。我的意思是，我在撰写疾病史时真正想做的事情之一，就是拓宽视野，确保我们不仅仅聚焦于那些性感的大型疾病——
whether it's kind of these lesser known diarrheal diseases or worm diseases or particularly tropical diseases that sometimes European or American historians don't pay very much attention to because they're maybe not the sort of local history diseases. But even so, so I comment this from a perspective where not inclined to put plague at the top of the pyramid of wildly crazy, insanely deadly diseases, but it's there. I mean, I still just am struck and looking at the whole swath of the history of infectious disease and how hard it really is to wrap your mind around bubonic plague. So
无论是那些鲜为人知的腹泻病、蠕虫病，还是欧洲或美洲历史学家有时不太关注的热带疾病，因为它们可能不属于所谓的地方史疾病。即便如此，从我的视角出发，我并不倾向于把鼠疫置于那些疯狂至极、致命无比的疾病金字塔的最顶端，但它确实在那里。我的意思是，当我审视整个传染病历史的长幅画卷时，我依然感到极其震撼，并且很难真正去理解腺鼠疫究竟是怎么一回事。所以
the plague caused by the bacterial disease Yersinia pestis. It's hard to understand how something could exist that causes so much disease and so much death so quickly on such scales. What is the current thinking on how much death it does cause? In the Black Death, we're, so I'm a Roman historian who's perennially jealous of scholars working in the late Middle Ages and early modern periods, because you still have pre-industrial societies, but you have more of a documentary record and, you know, in places like Italy, you, you have really rich record from civic, um, uh, governments and in England as well. And then increasingly from church records. So we actually have more of a basis than we do in the
由鼠疫杆菌（Yersinia pestis）引起的鼠疫……很难想象怎么会有这样一种东西存在，它能在如此短的时间内、以如此巨大的规模造成如此多的疾病和死亡。目前关于它到底造成了多少人死亡，学界主流看法是什么？在黑死病中，我们……我是个罗马史学者，我一直对研究中世纪晚期和近代早期的学者羡慕嫉妒恨，因为你们面对的依然是前工业化社会，但你们拥有更多的文献记录，比如在意大利等地，来自城市政府的记录极其丰富，在英国也是如此，接着还有越来越多的教会记录。所以我们实际上拥有比我们更多的依据……
Roman empire. And there's been a ton of work on the black death and it doesn't, you know, there's not like a sort of quotient that it hits everywhere it goes. I mean, there's one amazing, I use this one manor record from the South of England in the book that has been studied where you have this amazing list of people, workers on these villages from 1347 and 1349. It's just like this granular look at the arrival of the plague. And there are little like hamlets or something where it's killing nobody. Hamlets was killing everybody. So we're talking about an average of a spread, but the work on the Black Death, you know, that used to be canonically that it killed a third to a half, which I always think is kind of funny because it's sort of like just got ingrained. And there's all this history work that just says third to half, third to half, third to half. And, you know, that's not bad, but it's still pretty big spread.
罗马帝国。关于黑死病的研究已经有很多了，你知道的，它到达的每个地方并不是都有一个固定的死亡比例。我的意思是，有一个非常惊人的例子，我在书中引用了英格兰南部的一份庄园记录，这份记录经过了深入研究，上面列出了1347年和1349年这些村庄里的人民和工人名单。这就像是用极其细致的视角观察瘟疫的降临。有些小村庄或类似的地方，瘟疫没有杀死任何人；而有些小村庄则杀死了所有人。所以我们谈论的是一个平均的传播范围，但关于黑死病的研究，你知道的，过去传统观点认为它杀死了三分之一到二分之一的人口，我一直觉得这挺搞笑的，因为这好像已经根深蒂固了。所有的历史研究都在说三分之一到二分之一，三分之一到二分之一，三分之一到二分之一。你知道，这不算差，但范围还是相当大。
And anywhere there's like a ton of detailed evidence, it really is more like half. And it's usually these overtimes. Historians like to be critical and these big claims get kind of broken up. But actually what's weird about the study of the Black Death is that hasn't, in a lot of ways, really happened. I mean, there was definitely variability. But if anything, the older estimates tend to be on the lower end of what we think. So over really large areas, it's killing half the population. And the thing is, we sort of take the Black Death for granted.
而且在任何有大量详细证据的地方，实际情况确实更接近二分之一。而且通常这些数据会随着时间推移而修正。历史学家喜欢持批判态度，这些宏大的说法往往会被打破。但实际上，关于黑死病研究奇怪的地方在于，在很多方面这种情况并没有真正发生。我的意思是，肯定存在变异性。但如果要说的话，早期的估计往往处于我们认为的较低端。所以在非常大的区域内，它杀死了半数人口。问题是，我们有点把黑死病当成理所当然了。
We're familiar with the iconography. But we don't really probably think enough about what that must have meant i mean one in every two people is killed if you've got 20 friends 10 of them are dead you've got four kids two of them are dead and the other two will probably die anyway something else it's mind boggling so this is the most cataclysmic event in human history? Yeah, I mean, I think that there used to be, now, this is a useful contrast, the Columbian Exchange, so the arrival of European explorers and conquerors in the New World following Christopher Columbus, there used to be the idea that these unleashed these sudden huge pandemics that also killed 50, 60, 70% of the
我们对它的标志性形象很熟悉。但我们可能没有真正去深入思考这意味着什么——我的意思是，每两个人中就有一个人死亡；如果你有20个朋友，其中10个已经死了；如果你有4个孩子，其中2个死了，另外两个可能也会因为别的什么原因死掉。这简直不可思议。所以这是人类历史上最具灾难性的事件吗？是的，我的意思是，我觉得过去曾经有过——现在，这是一个有用的对比，哥伦布大交换，也就是欧洲探险家和征服者在克里斯托弗·哥伦布之后来到新世界——过去曾有一种观点认为，这些探险引发了突然而巨大的大流行病，同样杀死了50%、60%、70%的
population. Obviously, I think the introduction of European and African diseases to the new world is hugely important and killed massive numbers of people. And you can't talk about European expansion and colonialism without the biology of infectious disease. But those numbers don't stand up. There were some really, really big pandemics. And over the course of a century, there may have been that level of population change. But none of the, say, 16th century pandemics that we can follow were quite the same magnitude as the Black Death. Now, I still think they're sort of in that tier of the most destructive disease events in history. But I would say that the plague
人口。显然，我认为欧洲和非洲疾病引入新世界是极其重要的，并造成了大量人口死亡。如果不结合传染病的生物学，你就无法谈论欧洲的扩张和殖民主义。但这些数字站不住脚。确实有一些非常非常大的大流行病。在一个世纪的过程中，可能确实达到了那种程度的人口变化。但是，比如说我们能够追踪的16世纪的大流行病，没有一个其规模能与黑死病完全相比。现在，我仍然认为它们属于历史上最具破坏性的疾病事件那一档。但我会说，瘟疫
pandemics at their worst seem to just have a kind of scale and magnitude that we don't see in other events. And Carl, I mean, obviously, if you live in England, I guess also in America, the focus of the Black Death is Europe, particularly Latin Christendom. But there's a kind of a growing interest in the scale and the scope of the spread of the Black Death across Asia as well, isn't there? And there is research being done recently, suggesting that it actually spread the century before in the wake of the Mongols. Is that right? Yeah, there's all sorts of really interesting scholarship happening right now, partly driven by the ability to draw from genetics as a source for understanding the evolutionary history of these pathogens. And it's really reopened, really, the question of how big was the black death chronologically and spatially?
大流行在最严重的时候，似乎具有我们在其他事件中看不到的一种规模和量级。卡尔，我的意思很明显，如果你住在英格兰，我想也在美洲，黑死病的焦点是欧洲，特别是拉丁基督教世界。但人们对黑死病在亚洲传播的规模和范围也越来越感兴趣，对吧？最近有一些研究表明，它实际上在蒙古人兴起之后的上个世纪就已经传播开了，是这样吗？是的，现在有各种非常有趣的学术研究正在进行，部分原因在于能够利用遗传学作为来源来了解这些病原体的进化历史。这确实重新引发了关于黑死病在时间和空间上究竟有多大的疑问。
And certainly there's a lot going on in the evolutionary history of the bacterium about three generations before the black death. And this is interesting because it really, I think even deepens the overlap with the Mongol mongol expansion um and the the establishment of mongol empires in the the 13th century so um so that's a really interesting angle and then just i think we're we're living in a time where there's a lot more global history that doesn't sort of just start with you know england i mean england is sort of the very fringe of what's what's happening in the black death and it comes from central as. We always, even without the genetic evidence, the Arabic evidence, Arabic language evidence
而且毫无疑问，在大流行发生前大约三代人时，该细菌的进化历史发生了很大变化。这很有趣，因为我认为这确实深化了它与蒙古人扩张的重叠，以及13th世纪蒙古帝国的建立，所以这是一个非常有趣的切入点。然后我认为我们正生活在一个拥有更多全球历史的时代里，这种历史不仅仅是从你知道的英格兰开始——我的意思是，英格兰只是黑死病中所发生事件的极其边缘的部分，它来自中亚。我们总是，即使没有遗传学证据，阿拉伯语的证据
for the Black Death is extraordinary. And we know as richly what happens in Egypt as we do from Western Europe. So it's a story that always should have been. But China, China is interesting, isn't it? Because there the evidence is more ambivalent. Yeah. And it's hard for me as a scholar because the language in East Asia are so inaccessible to me.
关于黑死病的阿拉伯语证据也是非同寻常的。我们对埃及发生的事情的了解和对西欧的了解一样丰富。所以这是一个本应如此的故事。但中国，中国很有趣，不是吗？因为在那里的证据比较矛盾。是的。作为一名学者，这对我来说很难，因为东亚的语言对我来说太难接触了。
And there's a huge level of interest and a lot of debate going on now. And there's smart, informed people who seem to be on both sides of this. So it's very hard for kind of an outsider to really know are these attestations of pestilence in China in the 13th century, is that part of the Black Death or the big bubonic plague pandemic, or is it not? And I really am unconvinced that either side has the decisive win in this argument right now. But it's one of the things we are going to find out. It's exciting. We need to know. It's really cool to try and ask.
现在有很高的关注度和很多争论。有很多聪明、见多识广的人似乎站在这个问题的两边。因此，对于一个外行来说，很难真正知道13世纪中国关于瘟疫的这些记载，是黑死病或大型腺鼠疫大流行的一部分，还是不是？我真的不相信任何一方目前在这个争论中取得了决定性的胜利。但这将是我们即将发现的事情之一。这令人兴奋。我们需要知道。尝试去探究这真的很酷。
If it does get to China, then it widens the scope of this pandemic. If it doesn't, then we need to ask why wasn't it there. And for instance, in South Asia, too, I think we don't fully know. But I would say there the balance of the evidence still suggests that the Black Death doesn't get to India in the 14th century, and we don't really have a good explanation for that. But it was big and bad. It was big and bad where it was, for sure. Now, that is the end of today's episode, but tune in tomorrow when we'll have the next installment. Or, alternatively, you can always join the Rest Is History Club at restishistorypod.com
如果它确实传到了中国，那么这就扩大了这场大流行的范围；如果没有，那么我们需要问为什么它不在那里。例如，在南亚也是如此，我认为我们还不是很清楚。但我会说，那里的证据权衡仍然表明，黑死病在14世纪并没有到达印度，我们对此并没有很好的解释。但它确实规模宏大且极具破坏力。它在它所到之处确实规模宏大且极具破坏力。好了，今天的节目就到这里，但请明天继续收听我们的下一期节目。或者，您也可以随时加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部（restishistorypod.com）
and you'll get it straight away. We never miss a promotional opportunity. Anyway, for the time being, it's goodbye from me and it's goodbye from him. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
然后你就可以立即收听。我们绝不会错过任何宣传的机会。不管怎样，暂时来说，我是主持人，向大家道别，他也向大家道别。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余烬》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八卦八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。